for that clearly either you guys have
accidentally just come both in your
hockey regalia or we got ourselves going
on it's sports game season well second
at the blocks are giant novelty shirts
what team what team are you heroes
marrakech these are the Buffalo Sabres
very the great one Kish I'm from Buffalo
so this is my home team I'm the only
east coast mother in here these really
echoes yeah yeah Howie chooses yeah
Bruins released coast all right the
leading lights at least yeah these my
country so smaller basically from every
Coast Ike to leave me hanging as well
jerk Eric Iceman tailing out who you
with i am the san jose sharks okay
sharks synonymous with ice makes your
gross fish nice sharks you don't have
any allegiances to our teams we don't
worry don't play in the hole we have a
game where we don't play on ice called
her leg which is so it's unprofessional
oh yeah play on the street corner
outside bars at 3am we don't want to my
shirt I think we make fun of those games
when we're playing games wow how I'm
gonna make fun of you cuz i have a
feeling arte is gonna take you to school
i've i've had this coming for some time
yeah but my pride won't allow me to not
play mary you were good at NHL but
unfortunately for you Eric Tay is may be
quite a bit better you were the a pro
good at everything alright at this gay i
have i mean like i played a thanks a lot
he's too good I've led a lot of like NHL
games throughout like growing up and I
haven't stuck to the series necessarily
but just knowing the game like knowing
the sport and like watching the sport
helps you like beef up for you right
like you watch soccer all the time so
you can make plays you can see the pitch
better like and damn things like maybe
she asian of network exactly my ghost
games all time to I do i do i've been to
sharks games let's get into this guy
yeah I'm ready hockey I was just showing
some of the stabs because some people
like looking at that um no don't just go
away from that I don't want to see
really by numbers why are they not
higher than the San Jose numbers because
I made a Stanley Cup oh they won the
stanley cup did the san jose team news
i'm ever
oh shoot the Kings win does it does
there minigame where there's riots
outside of e3 or if they lose my
controller chase went a secret is to
just select see Tommy let me wait for
him yeah he doesn't want to play anymore
water I just yeah I just insta lose your
guys production production you can't
roll to stop that I think it might have
died just having some bats I'll fix it
up like I stay NHL 94 I also wanted to
make it clear just how low my saber
steps are in case it has any bearing on
possibly what happened during the game
alright yeah you're one of the lower
ones while we made for four batteries to
comieron advantage while we wait for
batteries to come in Mary we you've got
a list of a dumb stuff and funny oh yeah
you might have noticed this piece of
paper that kind of looks like a resume
but it's actually in fact a list of all
the things that are missing since NHL 14
which a lot of people have been pretty
frustrated with pay no attention to any
noises that you might hear you it's
fascinating I was like looking up a lot
of the features that we're missing to
see like how bad it was or you know if
it's there like minor issues and it's
it's a legitimate list was great so we
had NHL 14 last year was not on next-gen
consoles this is the first like xbox one
ps4 NHL and this thing happens there as
well all this stuff yes okay uh no GM
connected no online team play no EA
sports hockey league no EA sports arena
no online shootouts live the life be a
legend winter clinic all gone winter
Claude no create a team there's no
custom camera option there's the only
way it is no creative ah there's no it
is even like little things there's no
top three stars at the end of the game
some of the stuff is going to be really
yeah that's a bit weird and it's a very
small thing so a lot of this stuff is
going to be added in later I believe
that they've mentioned there will be a
patch in October where they're going to
be adding a lot of these additional
features from you know being able to
play online team play is a huge one so
let's act like you can't look like one
on one that's right so like in online
team play it's like 12 people online
all play each individual player which is
really cool they're going be adding that
in in the patch that's a bit messed up
so this stuff happened to FIFA last year
where the next gen 1 didn't have like
some really peculiar stuff like
tournament mode which is basically a way
of just like playing the World Cup or
the Premier League without like having
to go into career mode was inexplicable
complicated can that be to just keep it
weird stuff like that you couldn't do
unranked friendlies like okay there was
like four different online modes but you
couldn't do that so it's weird I guess
this is what happens when you've got
like these massive teams who were
suddenly happy to be split down the
middle to make stuff for next gen Anna
and previous gen yeah it's it's it's a
bummer that they're doing that I I mean
like I said there is a patch where
they're going to be putting some of the
features back in and i would suggest
giving them your money in the patch
because I you know went until the game
is there I wouldn't really probably pay
for it oh it's a full game don't worry
the way it's going to know hard day for
a patch and like just cuz they say a
patch is coming does not mean a patch is
coming it usually does but when will it
come will come in October or like when
they say well come in december will come
in February like that and this da
remember what I'm about to forward I've
started something to never materialized
and the other thing I wonders I wondered
that they have to put this out on the
date because of licensing stuff like
they probably got a hell dolphin up but
that's a rumor yeah there's also am like
the fear because they've had issues with
other games where online has been broken
I mean like look at some of the other EA
games maybe they just didn't wanted to
make sure it wasn't broken yeah is a
reasonable fear I hope huh I guess in
this you know had a video game website
headline world perhaps it's better than
the headline it doesn't have multiplayer
is a bit better than yo this case much
greater world that players told ya kin
uh yeah anyway we're onto the ice
benching up Oh Gary the Sabres pushing
across the blue line going outside I go
for a really low percentage shot my very
few shots on goal trying to get
happening gonna get the one-timer action
that's that's always the key right yeah
burns you're bigger than that guy to be
fair the saber fell down I have more I
have more love in the game oh my god you
kicked it from me
I didn't know you do that there's all
kinds of checks in hockey body check
stick check pop check kick check
double-check head check no hip check
stolen but check elbow check check check
get out of my freaking way testing right
oje from distance here that's antti
niemi yeah yeah because his defense
could you Oh little spin mode doesn't
happen go go go hello icing icing it a
little lunch icing icing for Europeans
was like the off side over here your
guys was all about the better it out you
need the icing was pretty important like
the way you did cuz it prevents a lot of
injuries I have a delayed penalty coming
off really good I really have a
surprises everyone here we go here's an
upset oh my gosh that home is that home
field of an eyewear Eric creamed me
yesterday I think we got a pretty his
point and that was a goal I'm impressed
its myself up one goal to Eric's to see
you this is beautiful though like that
let's end the segment the crowd looks
really good although it does seem to be
the same dude yeah this game looks so
good it is good and I don't know if you
guys saw but the announcers are live
announcers it's like a real video it is
a bit weird but it looks good I think it
really is a testament to how good the
game look it's it's real video like of
actual dudes Thor film or like on green
snow it's like I'm wash it looks like
it's on me well that's the dumbest we go
so let's go on for it maybe get it
you're like I'm gonna get worked yeah
what is she right oh please it is also
doing man shut up against a bird he's
for tat now he's protecting his hug cuz
you guys will get off my butt oh good to
open upon the debt yummy big save oh
it's triangle why also know there we go
oh you got it you gotta like I think you
have to raise it over the course of the
game you got to keep the anger building
up
and then and then you punch oh when the
gloves come off I think is important
though it is actually raises I believe
stats of the individual player hey
tickets the illness anybody home it's so
dumb okay I'll tell you I'll tell you
why fighting okay go on fighting is
important because if the refs don't do
their job in terms of like oh Jesus in
terms of like making calls and stuff
like that protecting the players you
have to be able to protect your players
and so by some that is some old Oh high
school that is you can apply that to
every sport if the refs aren't gonna do
it so we're gonna enforce it ourselves
yeah but nah no way for me oh that's not
gonna back you not good that was bad oh
that was a good that was a good patty
that was a good pass my passes are Oh
joking about the ground his helmet is
off East MD holy running my people
online can read about your people who
listen oh my god 2010 gogoli be a goalie
do a goalie do that goalie thing that
you guys are getting got some
distraction questions prying from the
twitch chat and games watch out noodle
legs asked how the goalie reactions been
improved they used to be pretty brutal
in the past doesn't seem that way Oh me
maybe you say they were too good before
oh really yeah how do you feel about
them they they're pretty strong it is
hard to make a goal I would say you
would say that oh oh no I'm coming a big
with the deist I think we're gonna
finish this off to the first quarter no
really honey seconds left this is it
this is your life oh my god your nose
what's good I can shut down
I can't believe Oh victory this is what
the Sharks do when they want to
intimidate players no this is power
player they go to it Jenna and its
really lamb I just want you guys to know
what do you want yours what is your
buffalo sabres power play falafel you
like it the double bird that's just what
I do whenever whatever i'm on the
Megatron yeah yeah nice work Asia NHL 15
review going up who's doing it um it
should be up today okay cool NHL 15
review coming soon I wonder if we ought
to do review in progress for that
because it's clearly not finished yet I
guess why never if they ship it that way
fired that yeah that's on them you know
cuz then hold you to make the argument
of like a mobo mmm oh right like you can
tell all the patch stuff doesn't happen
you suck eructation I know I alright
you're better at destiny we'll get you
back on for that later on